what's up everyone currently at piazza
del duomo at the duomo cathedral in
milano and italia and we are at the top
right now as you can see this is an
amazingly beautiful city and be talking
a little bit about something that i've
recently been thinking about a lot about
me versus us so we'll talk about that a
moment i want you to see this first look
at that gorgeous art and design gothic
architecture reminds me a lot of sagrada
familia españa and barcelona so yeah
we're currently at the top and the
piazza is below the plaza and milano is
a very interesting city because it's not
like Rome and Florence where the joke is
that it takes a hundred years for you to
move a brick because here they are doing
things like building skyscrapers and
they're moving things along quite
quickly when they want to do things
which something that I recently learned
from the hotel clerk that was checking
us in
so a little bit about the me versus us
some mentality I think that we have a
biological instinct within us to do
things on a mimimi basis and I think
that that's extremely important because
we have to figure out how to of course
survive get ourselves some water some
food some shelter and achieve the goals
that we set all this stuff but I think
we too infrequently think about us and
by us I don't mean a us I don't mean in
my tribe my five people I don't mean my
state I mean us as in all of the beings
all the energy on this planet figuring
out how to work together and move
forward because we are just recently
leaving periods of massive war over the
last couple hundreds of years and there
has never really been a period a very
long period of multiple centuries of
peace on the planet and so I think that
we can get there together but we have to
focus on the US and we have to focus on
things like peace with to focus on
things like abundance and not scarcity
the more that we focus on abundance and
the more that we focus on the southwest
Ness if everybody can subscribe to that
notion of selflessness overtime and
balance and with a little bit of me and
selfishness then I think we can get to a
more peaceful place so think about it
more often we think a lot about the meal
the tremendous amount about the meat but
let's think more about the us and let's
practice thinking more about the us and
where will that guide us over time
thinking about
because to me thinking about us means
thinking about prosperity means thinking
about collectively moving forward and
enriching the souls of everybody and
unleashing their potential into the
world and living beautifully and
harmoniously and I think that is the
ultimate challenge of a civilization
that devolves orbiting around the Stars
how do they evolved to become peaceful
and prosperous and the pinnacle of
prosperity in a civilization so much
love everyone thanks for tuning in from
Milano Natalia and we'll catch you soon